[Musique]
[Rires]
bonjour bienvenue dans ce premier numéro
de la saison de mode d'emploi avec un
focus sur les métiers de l'événementiel
mais aussi comment se former et les
entreprises qui recrutent
sans plus tarder voici le sommaire nous
irons à maurepas ou l'hôtel mercure
propose de nombreuses prestations pour
les entreprises et les particuliers
ce que projecteurs également sur la
société une image qui met en lumière et
sonorise plusieurs types d'événements
des métiers qui nécessitent une
formation spécifique vous saurez tout
sur la filière technique du spectacle
dispensée par l'école 3 juillet sera
elancourt enfin vous verrez quelles sont
les entreprises de notre territoire qui
recrutent dans ce secteur un conseil
prenez de quoi noter le secteur de
l'événementiel et dynamique il offre de
nombreuses opportunités notamment dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
alors les métiers sont multiples que ce
soit dans l'accueil ou bien la mise en
place technique d'un événement reportage
nous sommes aux portes des quartiers
d'affaires de saint quentin en yvelines
et de traque et l'entourent en plus de
ses 89 chambres l'hôtel 4 étoiles
mercure mon repas 50 ans dispose d'un
cadre idéal pour l'organisation
d'événements privés
ou encore professionnels méfier bonjour
jean nation vous êtes le directeur de
cet établissement
alors pourquoi vous avez souhaité
proposer une branche événementiel alors
c'est une décision du propriétaire des
lieux
lorsqu'il a construit cet établissement
dans les années 70 en fin d année 110 2
proposait alors que saint-quentin était
en plein développement comme quartier
d'affaires de proposer cette prestation
nous avons cinq salles de réunion et un
restaurant qui permet d'accueillir tout
type de réunion ça va de la journée
d'études c'est à dire les sociétés qui
sont installés dans le coin et qui ont
besoin de s'isoler pour des formations
ou des réunions de management et ou
technique d'ailleurs et nous avons
également des séminaires résidentiels
c'est à dire cette fois ci avec des gens
qui sont hébergés dans l'établissement
qui vont donc passer plusieurs jours et
utilise salle de réunion dans la journée
[Musique]
et justement parmi les salariés
responsables de la partie événementielle
yann jestin et responsable commercial
bonjour alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer en quoi consiste votre
métier
mon métier c'est de commercialiser
l'hôtel en globale c'est à dire que nous
avons un restaurant nous avons des
salles de réunion nous avons une
réception avec des chambres et du coup
nous devons faire le commercialiser le
restaurant les chambres et salles de
réunion donc mon métier à proprement
parler c'est de trouver des nouveaux
clients et que les clients habitués
reste et continue à venir et une
pression particulière je tente pour ce
côté événementiel a plus
particulièrement la pression elle est
surtout face aux clients ça que j'ai
connu d'autres secteurs où il ya une
pression face à la société qui nous qui
nous engage ici c'est le client qui nous
demande toujours plus j'ai moi ça fait
dix quinze ans que je suis dans le
milieu et j'ai vu l'évolution en disant
du client qui fait des séminaires de 80
personnes trois jours avant
alors qu'avant des souvenirs de 80
personnes ça se faisait trois-quatre
mois avant mais aujourd'hui tout est en
flux tendu c'est de la dernière minute
[Musique]
changement de décor et de lieux puisque
nous sommes ici à coignières c'est ici
que sont installés les locaux de la
société une image spécialisée dans
l'installation de matériel audio et
vidéo
elle intervient dans plusieurs
événements comme par exemple des
festivals des concerts ou encore des
conférences avec nous valérie b q
bonjour à manger alors pour quel public
travail une image une image travail pour
un public professionnels et
institutionnels pour des mairies des
conseils généraux des ministères à vous
proposer plusieurs plusieurs services en
dans votre société
est ce que font un petit peu nous
énumérer les différents métiers que l'on
retrouva à une image on retrouve à une
image les métiers de la prestation
technique en sonorisation en vidéo en
éclairages scéniques également des
métiers de
prestations d'installation puisque nous
installons des salles de conférences des
salles de classe également
quentin caporossi bonjour vous êtes à
une image depuis trois ans tant que
technicien ingénieur du son alors cela
consiste en quoi ça consiste
principalement en fait à installer des
systèmes de diffusion et des systèmes de
conférence pour des prestations par
assurer la sécurité des spectateurs émus
aux clients et quand on est sur le plan
comme on dit on doit installer vais
mettre en bonne fonction et bien sûr
respecter toutes les horaires de
diffusion et du spectacle
[Musique]
importée depuis 2002 en ile de france
une image est reconnue à l'échelon
national pour son parc matériel de micro
conférences sans fil et compte bien
poursuivre son développement à
l'international des métiers qui
demandent vous vous en doutez des
compétences alors si comme quentin que
l'on vient de voir dans le sujet vous
voulez travailler dans le secteur du son
et du spectacle je vous propose de
prendre la direction des longs cours et
de son école troisième
[Musique]
avec ses douze mille mètres carrés
l'institut international de l'image et
du son des yvelines est le plus grand
campus audiovisuel d'europe
il accueille un peu plus de 900
étudiants et propose plusieurs filières
comme le cinéma le journalisme
audiovisuel l'animation numérique et ce
qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui les
techniques du spectacle
[Musique]
il
simon trust bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
référent pédagogique pour la formation
technique du spectacle au sein de
l'école 3 i/s
alors quelles sont les différentes
étapes pour intégrer cette filière alors
la première étape pour intégrer nos
filières d'abord je dirais que c'est une
étape personnelle c'est la curiosité et
la motivation c'est à dire qu'il faut
avoir eu la curiosité s'intéresser à ce
type de métier et puis après il faut se
motiver pour avoir envie de venir parce
qu'il faut un diplôme particulier ça a
fait un pays où ils font tout ce qui est
technique du spectacle on accepte ou
sans diplôme
étant donné que vous faire ressortir les
élèves avec un équivalent bac et moi
j'estime que de toute façon ce qui est
important c'est d'abord quelqu'un qui a
envie de venir
puis après on se charge boulet lui
apprendre le métier vois pas pourquoi il
faudrait qu'il le connaisse déjà vont
arriver car la particularité c'est que
ces cursus peut se faire en deux ans
mais aussi en trois ans alors le cursus
des techniciens se fait en deux ans en
alternance en alternance ou pas
plusieurs ya plusieurs modes opératoires
mais de toute façon avec beaucoup de
périodes de stage départ de l'école qui
est le terme avec des périodes de stages
en contrats professionnels ou en
alternance ou en contrat d'apprentissage
et et après une autre formation qui sait
en trois ans qu'à la formation de
régisseur qui celle-ci les post bac
la qui sort trois ans
[Musique]
bonjour jérémy bonjour vous êtes en
troisième année
régisseur spectacle vivant oui est ce
que vous voyez un petit peu nous
expliquer ce que vous êtes en train de
faire
alors du coup là je suis en pleine
maintenance et nettoyage des lumières
automatique on à l'école pour les cours
histoire que soient prêtes à fonctionner
à chaque fois qu'on se reprend les sorts
quels sont justement les qualités
requises pour pour ce métier or une des
plus grosses qualités à mon avis ça va
être surtout la curiosité c'est très
très curieux au point de toujours aller
vouloir chercher plus vouloir apprendre
apprendre plus et parce que ça donne la
possibilité et la capacité d'exploiter
au maximum tout ce qu'on n'a à notre
disposition notamment à l'école ou même
au delà des cours on peut beaucoup
apprendre en allant vers les personnes
que ce soit d'autres personnes la
formation ou les intervenants ou même
les personnes de l'école pour en
découvrir un peu plus pour en savoir
plus pour qu'ils nous apprennent des
choses en retour
[Musique]
chaque année l'école 3e accueille une
centaine d'étudiants techniques du
spectacle
97 % d'entre eux trouvent un premier
emploi à l'issue de cette formation
voilà vous en savez désormais plus sur
les métiers de l'événementiel alors si
vous souhaitez vous lancer dans ce
secteur
voici ce qu'il faut retenir si comme ils
viennent de l'hôtel mercure vous voulez
être responsable commercial et vous
occupez d'événements il vous faudra
intégrer pendant trois ans après le bac
une école de tourisme ou une école de
commerce
concernant le salaire cela peut aller de
1500 euros net à plus de 3500 euros nets
l'évolution possible dans ce métier
directeur commercial enfin la qualité
indispensable pour durer savoir
s'adapter à toutes les situations
deuxième métier que l'on vient de voir
techniciens ingénieurs du son la
formation se fait en deux ou trois ans
dans une école d'audiovisuel en début de
carrière les salaires démarre à 1140
euros nets et peuvent dépasser ensuite
les 2000 euros
l'évolution possible ingénieur du son
enfin le petit plus dans ce métier
et bien c'est d'être débrouillards alors
maintenant si vous êtes à la recherche
d'un emploi notez bien ce rendez-vous
dans mode d'emploi nous donnons la
parole aux chefs d'entreprise aux biens
aux chargés de recrutement de notre
région alors justement voyons ensemble
quelles sont les entreprises qui
recrutent dans l'événementiel bonjour
nous sommes des sociétés l'ars traiteur
nous sommes implantés sur la zone
d'activités de saint quentin en yvelines
à magny les hameaux
nous sommes spécialisés dans
l'organisation de réceptions et la
fabrication de coffrets repas
nous recherchons pour notre production
du soir une équipe de cuisiniers avec
une compétence minimum c ap cinq ans
d'expérience si tout cela vous intéresse
merci de
nous envoyer votre cv à rh adlard ce
traiteur point com ou par téléphone au
01 30 50 2 61 65
bonjour je suis emilie blanc directrice
de recrutement pour le groupe pénélope
nous sommes une société de services aux
entreprises et nous recrutons tout
autant d'années des hôtes et des
hôtesses d'accueil en entreprise en
événementiel et des téléopérateurs dans
les métiers de la téléphonie
si vous souhaitez postuler envoyez nous
votre cv à recrutement @ pénélope point
fr ou appelez nous au 01 42 05 84 55
je m'appelle laurent iborra responsable
restauration à l'hôtel mercure de mon
retard actuellement je suis à la
recherche d'un poste de chef de rang
personnes expérimentées 2 ans minimum
d'expérience avec ou sans diplôme de
restauration le principal étant avoir
une expérience
ce poste à pourvoir rapidement pour des
horaires soient d'ouverture soit de
fermeture et occasionnellement de
coupure vous pouvez me contacter à
l'hôtel mercure au 01 30 51 57 27 vous
demander monsieur guy bourras laurent et
bien sûr n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer
vos offres de recrutement nous envoyant
un mail à redaction arobas et v60 18
points comme ce premier numéro de mode
d'emploi touche bientôt à sa fin mais
avant va voir ensemble les rendez-vous
liées à l'emploi qui vous attendent
on commence tout de suite avec le forum
yvelinois de l'apprentissage qui se
déroulera mardi 19 septembre de 10
heures à 16 heures à la mairie de
versailles
l'entrée est gratuite si vous vous
intéressez aux métiers de la logistique
la cité des métiers attrape organise un
job dating jeudi 21 septembre de 9h30 à
13h l'inscription est obligatoire sur
place on sent enfin si vous êtes à la
recherche d'un baby sitter pour vos
enfants par exemple ou bien que vous
voulez proposer vos services et bien
sachez que la mairie de montigny le
bretonneux organise un baby sitting
dating le mercredi 20 septembre de 18h à
21h et le samedi 23 septembre de 13h à
16h c'est sur inscription voilà c'est la
fin de ce premier numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi 26
septembre pour un nouveau
mode d'emploi consacré cette fois ci aux
métiers du commerce et de la vente à
bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]